uh we are going to be joined by
awardwinning journalist Sharon Carpenter
and uh
Sharon hi how you doing lovely to see
you again Sharon you should be here in
St Louis I know I know I'm GNA be there
in a few days actually right now I'm in
Sunny La you can probably sort of see
the palm trees behind me um but yeah we
worked together a couple of years ago
Yas it's so good to see you again yeah
it's wonderful and it's great that
you're going to come and join us for the
Gayla because that's our big uh
fundraiser if you will here in St Louis
and that's also going to be the site of
the closing ceremony of St Louis and the
grand chest store so we're looking
forward to seeing you yeah and Sharon we
are so excited to have you back for
strategy across the board so tell us
about your role this
year uh so it's similar to last year and
last year I had the opportunity to work
with Judith pogar who of course is
widely considered the best woman chess
player of all time didn't have to play
her at chess thankfully that would have
been over in in seconds uh but I got to
interview her live on stage and I'll be
doing the same thing with this year's
special celebrity guest who is Marina
toybina uh the sixth time Emmy
awardwinning costume designer who is
behind the costumes on the mask singer
she has worked with Katy Perry Justin
Bieber uh Taylor Swift if you've ever
heard of her of course we all have and
you're probably wondering uh what does
that have to do with chess well Marina
started playing when she was young she
was around 5 years old and in recent
years she's now using chess's
inspiration for some of her costumes so
if you remember Katy Perry's epic Super
Bowl halime show where you had the chess
piece costumes the dancers were in and
the giant chess board well it was Marina
who was behind those costumes and we're
going to be talking to her about how
chess has inspired her creatively but
also as an entrepreneur in business
she's learned some business techniques
uh when it comes to chess so it's going
to be very insightful and very fun as
well I I can't wait sounds fantastic
it's going to be wonderful having you uh
for the Gayla and for the closing
ceremony when are you going to come back
and uh do some chess commentary last
time uh you were throwing some patties
towards the end
there I'm coming in today surprise I'm
right around the Cor
cor hopefully I will be there very soon
uh with you guys on set that will
certainly be a lot of fun I think it was
2021 that we we worked together and
certainly learned so much working with
the best Grand
Masters um such as yourselfa so uh
hopefully I'll be back again soon maybe
next year what have you been up to what
are you doing in
La so I do do a lot of Royals coverage
these days of course chess is the game
of kings and queens right and
historically monarchs have always loved
to play chess so over the past few years
in particular there's been a lot of
interest in what's going on with the
royal family after the queen sadly
passed away and then Harry's book spare
and then the coronation happening this
year um so I've been very very busy with
that working with CNN contributing on
CNN and ABC News and and E news as well
and then I I cover pop culture in
general but I also love to cover chess
when I can too so um it's certainly
keeping me busy out here in La it
sounded there very very busy indeed Shar
and we did see you on social me media
playing a chess game so how's your
chess well have you read the caption on
that picture I lost to my uh 7-year-old
nephew which is sort of a Bittersweet
moment
right and I have to say my sister was
giving him some help as well and she was
using the oldest trick in the book like
the kids have to go to bed hurry up and
make your move and you hurry up and then
suddenly your Queen's gone like that
kind of thing uh was going down but I
love to see my nephew really getting a
good grasp of how to play chess and he's
enjoying it especially when he gets to
beat Auntie Shaz you know that was a
victorious moment and now my my little
niece who's five she watched it happen
now she wants to learn to play as well
so that's great well lovely well you're
inspiring uh I can see uh your niece and
nephew there Sharon thank you and once
again uh having you at the Gaya will be
a lot of fun we'll look forward to uh
seeing you on set that's all happening
December 2nd Joy it absolutely is
strategy across the board and it sounds
amazing for Marina and also Sharon to be
there and just to share with us there
chess experiences and their inspiration
absolutely Sharon thank you so much
thank you so much see you soon all right
see you soon see you soon